ja beinahe sechs monate krieg in der
ukraine und heute wollen wir unseren
ukraine blick einmal nach außerhalb der
ukraine richten wir fahren an in
russland in der stadt kimono wo das ist
etwa hier ungefähr 30 kilometer entfernt
von der ukrainischen grenze dort in
bezug belgorod hat es gestern abend
einen weiteren ja was soll man sagen
einen merkwürdigen unfall gegeben ein
weiteres waffendepot der russischen
armee ist dort kurz vor sonnenuntergang
hier mit einem großen knall explodiert
und hatten stundenlang gebrannt wir
sehen jetzt noch kurz aufnahmen von kurz
vor sonnenuntergang und jetzt sehen wir
wie es die nacht lang aus sechs stunden
lang hat hier gebrannt das ist
explodiert wir sehen jetzt auch gleich
feuerwehren links die hier schon die
gegend abgeriegelt haben wir haben
gehört dass er für 3000 menschen
evakuiert werden mussten das so scheint
es immer häufiger ist der nebeneffekt
von putins krieg in der ukraine der eben
zurück nach russland kommt und aus
welchen gründen auch immer immer mehr
russische armee basen russische
flughäfen russische militär depots eben
auch in russland und auf der besetzten
krim in schutt und asche legt
sie gehen zurück in die ukraine und
sehen hier relativ einzigartige
aufnahmen nämlich was wir hier erkennen
ist eine ja eine russische position wir
sehen überall diese kleinen gräben und
wir sind auch immer wieder eingegraben
diese militärfahrzeuge hier das ist also
eine schon verfestigte position wenn man
so will wo die ukraine die russen
aufgehalten haben die russen eine feste
front gebaut haben sich eingegraben
haben umso schwerer eigentlich für die
ukraine hier etwas zu machen und hier zu
schießen aber wie guck mal hier nach
unten hier fangen wir mal an und wir
sehen diese explosion und die ist eben
zielgenau und das so sagen die
ukrainischen einheiten die das
veröffentlicht haben können sie jetzt
hier noch mal angucken ist ganz neue
sogenannte excalibur munition excalibur
munition die auch von der deutschen
panzerhaubitze 2000 von anderen 155 mm
schutz der nato verschlossen werden kann
und das ist das besondere die eben auf
vier meter genauen gps gesteuert jetzt
hier
anpeilt und eben auch trifft wir sehen
das feuer hier in dem einen in den
graben wo dieser lkw steht und wir sehen
auch dass ich noch weiter dass weitere
ziele getroffen werden und
jetzt sehen was gleich hier oben wie es
gleich weitergeht mit den explosionen da
ist die nächste explosion auch wieder
genau auf dem ziel und ganz anders als
wir sonst immer sehen ist hier nicht aus
um alles mit kratzern übersät es gibt
quasi überhaupt gar keine krater links
und rechts davon sondern die senator
munition jetzt excalibur zum erstmal in
der ukraine eingetroffen ist so genau
dass sie tatsächlich mit jedem schuss
ganz genau ihr ziel trifft und
eigentlich fast gar nichts dagegen
danebengeht wir wissen da vielleicht
noch weitere explosion auch wieder genau
auf der position genau auf dem fahrzeug
das über 92 prozent der geschosse unter
vier meter weit vom angepeilten ziel
einschlagen das also für die ukraine
sehr gute nachrichten für die russen
extrem schlechte denn jedes ihrer
fahrzeuge braucht es noch ein schuss der
ukraine um vernichtet zu werden
apropos vernichtung am ende haben wir
noch mal sehr sehr krasse aufnahmen die
sind ein bisschen
verschwurbelt hier ein bisschen schnell
bewegen sich hier hat jemand zum ersten
mal aus dem atomkraftwerk ein
satirischer nämlich ein mitarbeiter der
gezwungen wird hier zu arbeiten hat
heimlich sein handy laufen lassen hat
also während des laufens heimlich
wahrscheinlich eine rose festgemacht
oder aus der tasche rausgucken sein
handy an gemacht und wir sehen hier den
generator raum diese atomkraftwerk ist
und jetzt sehen wir wie der mann oder
die frau sich in eine gegenbewegung
russische visionen russische militär
egger wir stehen alles voller russischer
militär lkw die russen und das ist zum
ersten mal der nachweis von innerhalb
des atomkraftwerks die russen verstecken
sich verstecken ihre armee hier sehen
wir es
12345 ural lkw stehen hier nebeneinander
verstecken ihre armee innerhalb des
atomkraftwerkes versuchen das so den
ukrainern unmöglich zu machen diese
atomkraftwerk anzugreifen und wir haben
die warnung in den letzten tagen immer
wieder gehört russland plant hier
provokation russland hat dieses
atomkraft sagt das größte atomkraftwerk
europas mit seinen soldaten mit seiner
militärtechnik vollkommen eingenommen
und versteckt sich dort und plant unter
umständen die provokationen die dann
auch eine super gau zur folge haben
könnten so die warnung der ukraine
[Musik]